في تطورات الساعات الاخيره في غزه افاد
مراسل الجزيره بان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قصف هدفا في مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه
وفي خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه قال مراسل
الجزيره ان اشتباكات وقصف عنيف ينفذ على
منطقه بطن السميم وحي الامل وذلك موازه مع
استمرار القصف المدفعي واضاف مراسل
الجزيره ان جيش الاحتلال قصف ايضا مسجد
الفاروق في مخيم خان يونس وسط اطلاق كثيف
للنار معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هاني
الشاعر هاني ماذا عن جديد
الوضع نعم عبد القادر في احدث الغارات
الجويه الاسريه كانت قبل قليل على منزل في
منطقه حي الجنينه في رفح دون ان تسجل
اصابات حتى هذه اللحظه سيارات الاسعاف
وصلت الى مكان القصف الاسرائيلي الذي كان
قبل نحو نصف ساعه من الان في المنطقه
الواق على وسط رفح حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم
الابلاغ عن وجود اصابات هناك اضرار ماديه
كبيره بفعل هذه الغاره في المنزل الذي
تعرض للقصف ومحيطه ايضا في خانيونس جنوبي
قطاع غزه هناك قصف عنيف في منطقه حي الامل
والبطن السمين وجره العقاد ومخيم خانيونس
وتسمع ايضا اصوات اشتباكات عنيفه في هذه
المحاور واطلاق لقنابل اناره من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه في محاور التقدم في
منطقه البطن السمين تحديدا ومحيط مجمع
ناصر الطبي فيما تعيق قوات الاحتلال تحرك
مركبات الاسعاف الى اماكن القصف
الاسرائيلي في المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه
خان يونس جنوبي قطع غزه هناك عشرات من
الشهداء ما زالوا في الطرقات منذ عده ايام
لم يستطع احد الوصول اليهم ايضا هناك
اطلاق نار صوبه مقر الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني الرئيس وقصف عنيف محيطه بحسب
الهلال الاحمر ايضا كان هناك في ساعات
النهار استشهاد لسيده فلسطينيه بالقرب من
هذا المقر وحاول بعضا من المواطنين الوصول
اليه وتم اطلاق النار صوبهم ما ادى الى
استشهاد اثنين بالتالي ثلاثه من الشهداء
وعدد من المصابين كانوا في هذه الحادثه
وتم دفن هؤلاء الشهداء في ساحه مشفى الامل
الواقع في المنطقه الغربيه لخان يونس
جنوبي قطع غزه ما تزال ايضا الظروف على
حالها والقصف متواصل وهناك تدمير عدد كبير
من المنازل في حي الامل والمخيم الغربي
ومنطقه بطن السمين ومنطقه جوره اللوت ايضا
وايضا منطقه جوره العقاد ووسط البلد بفعل
استمرار القصف الجوي والغارات التي كانت
في ساعات النهار والقصف المدفع الذي كان
في ساعات الليل وفي ساعات المساء المتاخره
من مساء يوم امس وايضا في المنطقه الوسطى
من قطاع غزه كانت هناك عده غارات على مخيم
النصيرات وغرب هذا المخيم وادى ذلك الى
ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء واصابه اخرين في
مدينه غزه بحسب الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
هناك قصف لمركبه مدنيه في منطقه تل الهواء
بالقرب من محطه فارس البطر وهناك استشهاد
ام و زوجها واربعه من ابنائها وهناك طفله
محاصره وتم ارسال سيارات الاسعاف الى هذه
المركبه ولم تستطع حتى اللحظه سيارات
الاسعاف بحسب الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني من
الوصول الى هذه الطفله الطفله الناجيه
الوحيده والمحاصر منذ عده ساعات في هذه
المركبه وانقطع الاتصال ايضا بطاقم
الاسعاف بحسب الهيال الاحمر الفلسطيني ولا
ولا معلومات حتى اللحظه عن مصير الطاقم او
حتى مصير هذه الطفله في احدث بيان صادر عن
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قبل نحو ساعه من
الان مدينه غزه شهدت ايضا غارات اخرى طالت
منطقه الصبره من بينها منزل وذا المنزل
ادى او او هذه الغاره على هذا المنزل ادت
الى نحو 20 شهيدا وفق معلومات حصلنا عليها
الى جانب غارات كانت في منطقه تل الهواء
والزيتون ومنطقه مخيم الشاطئ في ساعات
النهار وهذه الغارات كانت عنيفه مصحوبه
بقصف مدفعي طال مناطق عده كذلك وكاله
الغوث الدوليه قالت بان القوات
الاسرائيليه اقتحم عدد من مدارس الاواء في
منطقه محيط الجامعه الاسلاميه وحي الرمال
واعتقلت العشرات من النازحين بعد هذا
الاقتحام والذي سبقه بساعات عمليه قصف
مدفعي واطلاق نار في هذه المنطقه من رفح
مراسل الجزيره هالي الشاعر شكرا جزيلا
لك